is the Shroud of Turin a photograph of
Jesus resurrection I asked a historical
Jesus scholar who's written some books
on the Shroud to answer that question
for us but before I show his response I
just wanted to give a quick introduction
to the topic the Shroud of Turin is a
rectangular piece of linen cloth roughly
14 and 1/2 ft by 3 and 1/2 ft which many
people believe to be the burial shroud
of Jesus there's a faint sepia colored
image of a man's body on the Shroud the
front of a man and the back of a man the
cloth would have been spread out the man
would have been laid on half the cloth
and then the other half would have been
folded over him that's why there are two
images the front view and the rear view
that look like they're connected at the
head you can see some weird
discolorations on pictures of the Shroud
those aren't part of the image they're
damag from a fire but the image isn't
terribly impressive you might not even
notice it if you weren't paying
attention it just looks like a cloth
with some discoloration in the shape of
a man however in 1898 an Italian
photographer named sondo Pia took the
first photograph of the Shroud and later
when when he was examining the negative
he saw that the negative looked like a
photograph of a man in other words it's
the Shroud that's the negative so when
you look at a negative of the negative
it looks like a picture of a man a team
of researchers examined the Shroud in
the 1970s they thought they were going
to expose it as a forgery but most of
them became convinced that the Shroud is
an authentic burial clause
this led to a surge in interest in the
Shroud then in 1988 three different
Laboratories radio carbon dated the
Shroud and they concluded that the cloth
dates to between 1260 and 1390 a more
than a thousand years after the time of
Jesus since then there have been
repeated challenges to the reliability
of the carbon dating including more
recently a different dating method that
supposedly shows that the sh is much
older than the radiocarbon dating
suggested and the debate
continues but I asked Dr Gary habermass
who's written two books on the Shroud
whether he thinks it's a photograph of
Jesus resurrection let's watch his
response and then I'll share my
thoughts years ago uh not long after I
finished my uh my PhD I did my
dissertation on the resurrection of
Jesus
uh that was
1976 very short time after that the news
started breaking about the shroud of
turn in fact in 1978 was going to be the
most famous investigation of the Shroud
two years after I finished my my uh
dissertation in fact just about the same
time of the year um two years later two
years in a couple months um and I
decided to call a couple of the guys to
see if I can get some firsthand
information so I called one of the two
biggest named scientists from professors
from the Air Force Academy in very
various areas of the Sciences to ask and
they had signed a letter saying that
they wouldn't talk about this until the
results came out so he was really Leary
to talk about to me on the phone and and
uh he said you sound like a reporter I
said I'm not a reporter I'm a guy just
did his PhD and I'm I'm trying to do
researcher will you sound like a
reporter okay well that's because I'm
answering question he goes listen I
answered a few of your questions let me
tell you somebody who you who will talk
and he gave me the name of a fourth guy
that this started as a car poool with
four
guys professors at the Air Force Academy
in Colorado Springs they would go
together in a carpool well the guy I was
interviewing was one of the guys in the
carpool and he said let me give you the
name of our editor cuz he's used to
talking to people or asking questions
and it was another guy from the carpool
his name was Ken Stevenson the first
night I called Ken we talked for like 3
hours and I didn't even know him from
Adam and uh at the end of that
three-hour
conversation Ken said to me so you just
finished your dissertation of the
Resurrection right yeah
um you seem to know a fair B about the
Shroud well Ken I'm talking to you
because there's a lot more I need to
know hey this is Ken talking you want to
do a book together first first phone
call and so I
said well K I've got a lot of notes I've
already got a lot of it done but yeah
let's do it together so he and I did two
books together one in 1981 after the
investigation and one in 1990 after the
carbon4
um and in that first phone call it's
really interesting because I kept asking
things about this scientific test this
scientific test this scientific test I
had three hours of talking
and there were times in the tape when I
got to the resurrection questions Ken
could this possibly be radiation from a
dead body could you talk talking about a
quasi photograph here and you could
still hear this on my tape because he
gave me permission to uh to tape the
call call and he would do this two or
three times he goes turn your tape
recorder off I turned the tape recorder
off and he starts telling me about
Resurrection I said okay Ken turn the
recorder back on good enough turn it
back on back to science back to science
back to science hey Ken on that radio on
the X-ray thing can I ask you a question
about whether that's a photograph of the
Resurrection turn your tape recorder off
tape recorder off more so that was our
very first call now it's a long time
later this was about this was uh
70677 when Ken and I talked and it's a
long time from them I mean I mean it's
like almost 50 years from that point but
the major view has not really changed
critics hate it and critics will go out
of their way to say I faked it I've done
this a bunch of bull that's like people
living in their parents' basement saying
I'm a scholar and I'm 17 and I've been
to school but I don't think Jesus lived
well the guys who are saying I I put
pain on a cloth and I can prove you can
yeah they submit it and that flunks
every test if because it's not the same
data it's on the Shroud let me start by
saying you can you can take any
scientific machine or testing procedure
we have
today and to this day 50 years later you
cannot do duplicate the Shroud with
accurate chemistry and physics that's
one mystery you can't duplicate in fact
one of the main guys in the Shroud who I
started calling these guys around for
our book one of the guys a Yale a Yale
professor said to me the problem is the
physics contradicts the chemistry and
the chemistry contradicts the physics
you're getting different results but
that's just the data something's going
on here that's very strange and so I go
okay thanks for that and I'd kind of
store this stuff in my mind and uh and
go on well the the evidence for whether
the Shroud is the photograph of Jesus
which by the way a 1978 book by a a
journalist but I think he's had a degree
in history from Oxford uh Ian Wilson way
back in 78 if I remember the date Wilson
endered his book by saying the Shroud
could be a photograph of the
resurrection of Jesus a year before they
did the investigation so today they're
saying almost the exact same things
there have been a lot of tests in a
bunch of Laboratories in scientific
areas of universities arguing that the
image on the cloth is one two at least
two kinds of radiation now here are the
facts we have hundreds of burial
garments in existence and these burial
garments they have two different kinds
of marks on them decomposition and blood
I guess the blood would be decomposition
too but maybe the blood came before the
guy died who knows blood and
decomposition hundreds of Bearer
garments in European museums and they're
put away in the basement and you can get
them the Shroud has an IM image on it no
other ancient barrier garment has a body
image and because the man of the Shroud
was buried this way so that if you open
up the cloth is attached in the middle
if you open it up the bottoms of the
feet and the tops of the feet are going
to be in opposite ends the back of the
head and the and the face are going to
be right in right at the beginning and
you have the chest down to the toes and
the back of the head down to the heels
that's how the Shroud looks and no other
cloth has an image on it so we're
starting to put a few things together
here you can't duplicate it even today
no other body images from hundreds of
cloths there's no paint dye powder or
foreign substance in the image area that
can account for the image yeah there's a
lot of foreign substance people are
painting it there's specks of paint that
flew on it there's insect Parts there's
pollen there's things on the Shroud but
notice my words there's no foreign
substance on the Shroud that could
account for the image a speck of paint
here doesn't say the whole thing was
paint because when you look down here
there's no paint in fact there was
really no paint pigment D on the Shroud
to speak of it all so that's another
mystery there's some more Mysteries one
is called non-
directionality uh when we fake something
you start doing this think about
coloring you get tired
that's
directionality the Shroud happened like
this in fact we have a photograph in one
of our books of directionality on the
Shroud it looks like you took a
lampshade off a lamp and photographed a
bulb where you can't see the bulb you
just see that's directional there's no
directionality on the Shroud the Shroud
image is superficial Okay now what's
Superficial mean take a thread you blow
it up under a microscope the thread is
big big the thread might be made up of
200 fibral and the image on the Shroud
is only one fial deep now what do we
know in chemistry and physics where
something doesn't go to the back of a of
a a dry powder application you're going
to get some residue a superficial image
very difficult to explain un
non-directional very hard to explain but
here are the two probably the two most
difficult things to explain on the rub
it was noticed in the late '70s that
folders of the Shroud are
three-dimensional now here's why
three-dimensional is interesting there
are no true three-dimensional photos
here you get they were invented by the
Voyager space shot to get a space to
Jupiter shot or a space to Saturn shot
it's a distance thing but on the Shroud
the man's buried like this with his
hands in front and he's stretched out
he's dead one reason is his head is
Frozen like this he's in a state of reg
mortis is postm blood flow separation of
blood and serum nobody would question
the man in the Shroud is not dead he's
dead storig mortise kind of hard to fake
so he's like this and he's dead his
head's Frozen forward oh by the way the
knee is popped up like this that's
rigort that's R mortis has gone back
into its situation on the cross this
guy's been crucified he's got major
wounds two in the wrists two in the feet
and a and a big side W right here that's
just short of 2 in across blood and
Water by by the way blood and water from
that opening okay so you've got this
image no other images superficiality
non-
directionality but they put it in the
machine and the image is 3D what does
that mean well when the body is like
this and you put the top one over them
like
this that means the the cloth touches
the forehead the nose and the chin it
doesn't touch the ears it touches my
hands on top of my chest but doesn't
touch my rib cage it
it's on top of the knee here but what
about the knee that's down below it you
drape the cloth over it what about this
the interesting thing what 3D shows is
the whole image is there where the body
didn't touch the cloth so now the blood
is a contact stain the blood is there
because the cloth was on the wounds the
image is not a contact image it got
there by something else and today the
leading theory is that two different
kinds of of radiation caus the image on
the Shroud now just as much as we we
call a photograph a color photograph
that someone can show you or you have on
your phone but we also call a photograph
if you have a broken arm and you go get
an x-ray you can say yeah they showed me
the photo and uh yeah it's broken so I
mean radiation is a kind of photo too
it's a of of an actual image and so
that's where you get this the image of
the cloth could be a photograph
now is a man Jesus I mean
just a few years after his death
thousands of Jews are crucified in
Jerusalem what about somebody else well
there's some issues there uh how come we
don't have any why don't then why don't
we have any body images on the other
hundreds of barrier cloths that we have
why only this one okay another one he's
got something pressed down on his scalp
that's made wounds all the way through
his scalp why do you put something like
Thorns I would even say Crown that's a
little bit prejudiced I can just see The
Thorn holdes why would you put that on a
criminal oh because they thought he was
claiming to be the Messiah ah now you're
cheating if they crucified him in
Jerusalem there's nobody there who
thinks he's the Messiah that they're
putting up there putting a crown of
thorns on so why this guy why does he
have what things that were done to Jesus
were not normal crucifixion procedure uh
you might for example
argue um by the way Josephus argues that
even people capital punishment were
given individual burials because the
Jews valued the body but you might argue
that they would throw crucified bodies
in the trash sheep in the burning
smoldering trash sheep in Jerusalem why
was Jesus buried individually in a in a
beautiful cloth in a rich man's tomb
well how do you know it was a rich man's
tomb well there's not dirt all over the
thing he was in a in a atmosphere where
you know he's you know he's buried in a
in a tomb that's what you have when the
the cloth is in such good shape he
wasn't thrown on the ground decomposed I
mean the the cloth decomposed so and you
go all oh well that's sort of like Jesus
yes but not like the 70 people in
Jerusalem so it it looks like it's
narrowing down to Jesus but how sure am
I do I think it's the be it's the the
burial Garment of Jesus and second
question is it the
resurrection um I teasingly when I
people ask me that I'll teasingly say
yeah it depends on what side of the bed
I got up on this morning uh if it's
sunny out and I'm going to go fishing
it's a nice day man shroud's 90% if it's
a dreary day and I'm not you know I feel
a little bit down today it's probably 70
I mean I really do I I reassess and I
have different percentages at different
times uh I think there's a good argument
that shroud is Jesus's you go well why
do you leave a question mark Cuz I have
to leave room for the fact if you want
to be scientific or inductive you have
to leave evidence for the fact that
somebody might be able to fake it or
somebody might find evidence of a
crucifixion victim in 70 AD who they
they put a thorn crown of thorns on for
a criminal or buried in an individual
tube I think for the most part
though the Shroud looks like a an image
now the latest data part of this
3D it's widely believed that you can see
the teeth on the Shroud not because the
the lip has been ripped but you can see
the lip you can see the teeth through
the skin you can see teeth now if you're
seeing
teeth with a mouth that
shut something had to come out now we
used to say in our early lectures we
don't know if the the radiation would
come down this way or if it came out
this way but if this is teeth as one
doctor said to me when I was giving a uh
two said to me when I was giv this
lecture in the Shroud I show my slides I
go nah n nah it's right there you see
that teeth yeah it had to come out from
the inside the X-ray had to come out
from the inside because it brought the
teeth out on the cloth but you can also
see the bones in the back of the hand
they think you can see a backbone
through the front but especially the
fingers the fingers look very very long
because you're looking all the way up
into the hand so there are several
places that that look
like the radiation came out from the
inside it's looking more and more like
you know this man's dead so the moment
would have to be captured if it were
Jesus it have to be captured when he's
dead as he is starting to rise at
precisely that moment otherwise you'd
say hey man that dude's alive well yeah
he's alive cuz he's coming alive no no I
mean he didn't die on the cross so
you're in this Catch 22 he's
dead but something looks like it's
coming out of them so I I usually list
the Shroud as enough of an evidence that
it demands an answer I don't compare it
to my minimal facts argument where I use
the lowest common denominator day
and say that on the lowest data that
critics will admit there's still a
resurrection I think that's by far the
strongest argument for the resurrection
but because I use that minimal facts is
the biggie and parts of it as biggies
James the empty tomb Paul that doesn't
mean the Shroud doesn't belong up there
so sometimes I throw it into debates I
throw it into I did two co-author two
books with Ken and just recently I'll
end with this just recently the carbon
14 has been exploded
um because they've disproven the 88
carbon 14 they don't have a date for
what it is but they have discovered and
it's been published in an Oxford Journal
interestingly enough if I get the story
correctly one of the guys whose names on
the 88 carbon 14 argument that said it
was medieval is the editor of the
journal that published the new piece
that said the 8 carbon 14 is all wet and
I can I can give you the argument uh for
how the carbon 14's been destroyed but
right now we have have all the pro
evidence for the Shroud the only con
evidence was basically was the 8 carbon
14 now it's destroyed so the way is open
here to move ahead and say the Shroud
could really be the real thing and it
might be a photographic empirical piece
of data for the
resurrection so Dr habas says his
confidence that the Shroud is authentic
fluctuates between 70% and
90% my confidence that the Shroud is
authentic generally hovers between 20%
and 30% if I watch an awesome
presentation on the Shroud by an expert
in the field who shows me a bunch of
epic pictures of various details I might
temporarily get to 50/50 but then I'll
eventually fall back to maybe it's
authentic but I'm going to need to see
how some of these ongoing debates turn
out the main issues for me are these on
the one hand radiocarbon dating is
pretty reliable it's not perfect but
it's pretty reliable I know there are
responses and claims about contamination
but the three Labs dated the Shroud to
between 1260 and 1390 and that lines up
really well with how far back we can
trace the Shroud the documented history
of the Shroud meaning our earliest
records where we know they're talking
about the Shroud of Turin go back to the
1300s there are sources mentioning a
burial cloth of Jesus before that but we
don't know if they're referring to the
Shroud of Turin so we can trace the
Shroud back to the
1300s and that's when the 1988 carbon
dating says it was made when I see
different lines of evidence converging
it's pretty strong in my mind on the
other hand this is a very very strange
image if it's a forgery it's the most
amazing forgery in history I mean how
would someone in the 1300s anticipate
that someone more than five centuries
later would have this thing called a
camera and that if you take a photograph
of the Shroud and you look at the
negative you'll suddenly see a very
clear picture of a man's body front and
back someone in the 1300s couldn't have
anticipated that so it would have to be
an
accident but that image is some accident
so there are people who believe that the
Shroud is a forgery there are other
people who think the Shroud isn't
authentic but it's not a forgery they
think someone may have made it for a
Christian play in a church and then it
got stored and someone else found it
later and thought it was the actual
burial cloth of Jesus either way it's
pretty amazing that someone accidentally
made what amounts to an enormous
photographic negative of Jesus in the
1300s there are lots of other
interesting features of the Shroud Dr
habermass mentioned a number of them
another interesting detail is that the
wounds on the head of the image on the
Shroud line up pretty well with the
blood stains on a cloth called the
sudarium of ovetto which is believed by
some to be a cloth that was wrapped
around jesus' head after he died and the
sudarium can definitely be traced back
to the 6th Century so so it would be
another huge coincidence if some guy
making the Shroud in the 1300s not only
made a photographic negative but also
got the wounds to match the blood stains
on a completely different cloth in a
completely different
location then there are the alternative
dating methods one recent study suggests
that the Shroud is much older than the
three Labs concluded in
1988 what does that mean does that mean
I should Proclaim this study to be the
new proof that the Shroud is
authentic no because they're going to be
responses to the new dating and I'll see
how those responses go but what do you
think about the Shroud do you think it's
real do you think it's a photograph of
Jesus
resurrection do you think it's fake let
me know in the comments section
[Music]